dan zetterstrom of the ufo podcast and
the link to his podcast will be in the
description his and andy's asks great
guy by the way he's doing a lot of great
work that's why great great lead in by
the way because you're asking what can
you do that's a guy who's and like what
you're doing is exactly what you guys
should be doing great great
a tip focused on military encounters did
you ever come across cases where people
had experienced high strangeness similar
to that found on skinwalker ranch for
example
have any pilots reported things like the
hitchhiker effect you know
what a great question and i know
[Laughter]
oh my goodness i'm gonna have to buy uh
buy dana beer for that one um
great for by the way he's putting me on
the spot and and
you know that's that's that's that's a
great question
um
i want to answer this as accurately as i
can without without
without uh giving anybody the wrong
impression
there's a reason why the six observables
biological effects
okay
that by definition is high strangeness
people after an encounter
experiencing
certain
physiological and psychological
uh um
[Music]
things
um
again i i
let me let me
to put it succinctly yes
but not
not the same
as as the skinwalker ranch
differences being well you know the skin
walker was looking at a lot of the the
the paranormal aspects
um
as you say in the vernacular you know
shape shifters and
uh i think it was
ghosts and and
you know uh poltergeist that type of
activity whereas atip was looking at
nuts and bolts ufos
um
but there there were some some some
parallels
some people
uh and the question the problem is we
don't know
we really don't know enough about that
um
about the uap
issue to really to really speak cogently
on that
people had biological effects and that's
just that's as far as we were prepared
to go at the time
because that could be quantified and
qualified you can look at physiology and
morphology and you can look at things
like that and you can look at at tissues
and things like that you can quantify
and qualify
the other stuff is a lot harder um
especially anything dealing uh with with
the you know a psychological episode
when i say psychological i mean a bad
way not like it's made up i mean
everything we do is interpreted
psychologically right
there's a mental process that goes along
with it with a physical experience
ptsd is a perfect example ptsd is very
very real but it's a psychological
uh response to a to a physiological and
emotional type
situation
and uh very much the same way you know
people people will will process data
differently
just like ptsd
and and no different in this topic you
know you have people in some cases i've
talked to who
like dave fravor just wants to get
behind the wheel one of these things
learn how to fly it
then you have other people who've been
been
deeply and emotionally impacted by this
and still carry that with them for
whatever reason they've they've come up
close and personal and um you know it's
it's caused uh
it caused some sort of conflict
internally um i'll tell you a great guy
it's a super super guy
um
he was on one of the episodes of um
of unidentified he he carried the secret
around he he told us chain of command he
was up in canada doing a
a uh a maneuver with the united states
and him and his buddy
were situated fairly close to each other
guarding some you know enema field made
like a depot out of middle of nowhere
and and encountered a ufo
well they go to report it um
but his buddy recants the story and says
no it's all made up because of the the
the backlash that they received
and and he always maintained the story
and he was he was left out in the cold
people thought he was crazy and he
carried that around for a long long time
until one day
his buddy come out and and vindicate him
he says you know what
because i talked to the guy he said it
was real every bit of it i was there but
i didn't want to catch crap any longer
so i recanted the story and and i left
my friend out there to
to to flap in the wind so to speak and
um
you know it i that caused a lot of a lot
of
i'm sure a lot of issues imagine you
know being part of something
extraordinary and then
uh
the person that saw it with you telling
the world nah
you know we're just kidding we didn't
really see it and you know you did and
have to carry that for 20 30 years only
to come back later his name's dave
marceau uh he's a great guy if you ever
get a chance to meet him i highly
recommend you have him on your show
he carried that around his you know in
his soul for for for decades
and um you know you should ask him the
type of
uh
emotional cost
it took on him
um you know people call you crazy people
call you liar people call all sorts of
things
only at the end to find out that you
know what you were right
and it did happen
and the witnesses were coming out now
saying yeah it did happen um
you know that yeah there's there's you
know you say hitchhiker effect i i
you know some folks swear that once you
have one of these encounters there's
there's this hitchhiker effect and
and now all of a sudden
all sorts of weird things start
happening to you and your family
um
you know there's an individual that i
that i i'm very very very close to who
is very senior in this effort
um who at some point when it comes out
of the shadows you should probably have
this conversation with that person
um
because they'll tell you absolutely yes
but
you know again i
i don't have any data that can be
quantified or qualified so i
i i cannot speak definitively on it i
think we have to remain open
um
that you know there's a whole lot of
things that are possible
and i know you said you don't have data
that's quantifiable but i'm curious
about this hitchhiker effect or the
sixth observable is that associated with
proximity to the craft or length of time
looking at the craft like another
variable damn what is associated with
great questions man um
let me take a pass on that for now i'll
let me
that will be addressed um
sure